Đến qua sinh gặp bò qua viet hối tuổi tại quản thân gà hay nâm.
Gô cai cô la Food Box là nên tả kết nối các quán năng đường phố chất lợp tại Việt Nam
giúp bảo bảo bảo mát để chảy giả phẩm thực độc thảo cho thực hách chẻ.
Điều đẩn này chính là phản thân gà hay nâm tại quần 1 thành phố chiming
bởi hơn 8,5 phát triển giới sự rất rất phát của chú vinh
đầu biếp tại hoà và tập tâm, nếp mình chỉ còn phố khá mẹt nhộ nhịp.
Quán năng đặc dấu ăn rao thóa tinh tế giảm thực sinh gà bò, chúng qua và Việt Nam
nhưng món ăn chứ dành như cơm gà hay nâm, cơm trên dân châu, hay cán củ xen hầm đôi hale
được chế biến tìm mi và giúp trọt tinh thần món góc với điều trình của hợp với khổ bị Việt Nam.
Thì gà được hấp để giữ độ mềm và ngọt.
Cơm được nấu tự nước gà bảo thơm, cũng nước họt cửng cây nẹ đặt chương.
Cơm thì theo phai tại quần cơm gà hay nâm cũng là một món ăn được thách yêu thích.
Thì theo được quay thuộc công trên lịch thân, giữ lấp dài sòn rụ và thịp trong về nọt
Cái nào thân hảo với cơm nấu thịn nước gà bảo thơm, mang đến trải nghiệp ở thực đại hấp dẫn.
Chúng tôi muốn kên định với mình tóc sáng tạo như không quên giữ hồn món ăn.
Không ra sẽ xe xe, rígu tận tâm và sự kết ở thân hảo giữa các món ăn cùng của cơm gà của la mắt lại.
Đã giúp quán chính phục cả những người họ tình nhất.
Cô chuyện về hôm vi và tình yêu ở thực của xú vinh tại món ăn ở phụ cà của la Food Box.
Là một dưu ăn được nhất, mang lại cả bứng cho nhiều thức khách tới đây.